- It's the real life
Frankenstein experiment
that tried to bring a
murderer back from the dead
but wound up killing
a man instead.
This is "Dark History".
[music playing]
London, December 5, 1802--
at 4:30 PM, a man
named George Foster
leaves a tavern with his
estranged wife and daughter.
At 5:00 PM, a nine-year-old girl
spots the family taking a walk
along the Paddington Canal.
Later that evening, George
Foster was seen at a pub
sharing a drink with a friend--
his wife and daughter
no longer with him.
The next morning, John Atkins, a
boatman on the Paddington Canal
begins his day's work.
But something's not right.
He inspects beneath
the bow of his boat
and discovers the body of
George Foster's daughter.
Atkins is ordered
to sweep the canal.
Three days later, he finds
the body of Foster's wife
mere yards from where
she had enjoyed lunch
with husband and daughter.
Foster is arrested
for the murders.
Rumors swirled that
the trial was fast
tracked through the
influence of a Mr.
Pass, the right-hand man of
Giovanni Aldini, a respected
physicist and professor.
George Foster is found guilty.
He's sentenced to
death and dissection.
It was customary at the time
to cut the bodies of murderers
into pieces making it
more difficult for them
to rise from the dead with
God's chosen on Judgement Day.
But the body of George Foster
would not be dissected.
Instead, it is delivered
to Giovanni Aldini, who
is sorely in need of a
fresh corpse for a rather
macabre experiment.
Aldini is the nephew of Luigi
Galvani, a renowned scientist
who had developed a
method of stimulating
muscles with an electrical
current called galvanism.
Aldini is eager to
use this technique
to try to reanimate the dead.
On a cold and dark
January night,
a number of doctors
and curiosity seekers
gather in an operating theater.
Word had spread that
Giovanni Aldini would
attempt to raise the dead.
Aldini begins his experiment
by connecting conducting
rods to a powerful battery.
He then carefully applies
the electrified rods
to Foster's face.
Slowly, the jaw
begins to quiver.
And the muscles of
the face contort
into a grotesque grimace.
The audience watches
with a rising mixture
of fear and intrigue
when suddenly
Foster's left eye pops open.
With a terrified gasp,
many in the crowd leave.
What happens next is so
horrifying that it literally
scares a man to death.
Aldini uses a conducting
rod to probe Foster's body.
Suddenly the corpse clenches
its fists and punches the air.
Its back arches violently--
legs kicking back and forth
as if trying to outrun
its eternal damnation.
The body clanging against
the metal operating table
mixes with the
screams of onlookers
to produce a morbid
cacophony that echoes
throughout the
operating theater.
Mr. Pass, who secured the
body of George Foster,
is so disturbed, so
shocked, so horrified
he has a heart attack,
going to his own grave
believing that he
had helped bring
someone else back from theirs.
Aldini would continue his
experiments, touring the globe,
becoming world
famous, and inspiring
Mary Shelley's "Frankenstein".
He also developed a
small battery for the use
of experimenting on the dead.
That invention would become
the basis for our modern day
cell phone battery.
So be careful the next
time you answer your phone.
[ringing]
It could be the dead calling.